[Applause]
another flash mob protesting against the
recent executions on the streets of
yangon myanmar's biggest city
if caught they risk being jailed or
worse
but demonstrators say the executions
have made their opposition to military
rule even stronger
and one day the generals will face
justice
we should hold these brutal junta
leaders and the military accountable for
what they have done no exception for
anything
that's what people strongly believe now
for the families of the executed men the
anguish continues
these pro-military protesters came to
denounce jaw manu known as code jimmy
outside his house after his execution
his wife seen with him in this family
video has fled the home
but she told al jazeera from a hidden
location that the international
community must do more than just
condemning the executions
i would like to emphasize the importance
of impact in diplomacy not just talking
about a topic
in diplomacy condemnation and urging do
not work especially in the case of our
country myanmar
while there was much condemnation of the
executions at a recent meeting of
southeast asian foreign ministers there
was little talk of measures against
myanmar's military others are taking a
more proactive approach
chris gunness knew code jimmy when he
was a student activist and had worked
with him after his release from prison
now he's trying to bring a criminal case
against the junta in the turkish
judicial system
the johnson can run but they can't hide
there will be accountability against
them just as there was against the war
criminals in the balkans it took years
and years for milosevic and carrich and
raddish to end up in the hague but they
did up end up they did end up in the
hague we in map have accountability
cases criminal cases against the junta
all around the world
at the international court of justice in
the hague myanmar's already in the dock
in late july the court dismissed
objections saying that a case brought by
the gambia for genocide against the
rohingya ethnic minority can proceed
although the trial may take years the
wheels of justice are in motion
tony cheng al jazeera